okay hi everyone welcome to another
awesome language design review looking
at a variety of different
uh functions part of our incremental
language development series
all right first up
human evaluate it's a function we
thought about like 15 years ago
and um
[Music]
right
um
uh okay
that I I bet I have notes on this from
like at least
a decade ago see if I can find them I'll
tried skimming through the design
notebooks I have and it probably
predates those I wasn't sure if human
evaluate would be like a Mechanical Turk
sort of situation or
if it you know this is a subset of
reinforced learning from Human feedback
um well this is a yeah I mean it's a
somehow
hmm
interesting maybe I call the human
compute before
oh yeah 2015. there we go
decade wasn't too far off
um
okay let me see what I've got here
so they have
Mission with Carlo Ricardo and others
about the road map 2015.
um
okay
uh
let me just see oh boy file system has a
lot of these
[Music]
um
and they're all in are very confusing
oh here we go
project accumulator
post
okay there have been some summer school
projects
related to this
um I'm looking through sorry there's
mostly
things that are
yeah
I probably should have
figured this out beforehand
um
boy
something I should uh in my
um
there's a lot of things in my file
system which are currently only showing
up as
um dead cache hits
um
just a minute
is sorry
um
all right
okay we will be let's just see I'm sure
I can find I mean it's clear that there
was text about this previously
um
oh God okay what the heck I mean hold on
one second call
be able to find it I hope I'll be able
to find it here
just endless things called old files but
there was a one here
um
okay let's see if I can
oh see background material slash human
compute
okay this was from the 2018 summer
school
list of uh look at this
oh boy that one could be done well
better now respond about for spam phone
calls
um
let's see background material human
compute so let me just go find that
I think that one was in Dropbox that was
the one thing I saw about like human
stuff in your Dropbox
okay hold on let me try and find this
um
uh
well all right maybe we're starting wait
a minute there's background material
oh here we go
um
okay
well this is something here
um
words came from exactly
I don't know who myself is
[Music]
um
so we had had
a previous effort to connect to service
connect to Mechanical Turk really long
time ago anybody know about that
no I'm not sorry
that was the thing we had built when
Mechanical Turk was young
wow 2005
service connected that exist in 2005.
okay here I've got something 2007
um
uh let's see
it's a whole discussion for 2007 oh
there's somebody
who has an alternative to Mechanical
Turk that they were
trying to sell me on
um
looks like
okay looks like 2009
which is when wolf malpha came out we
had a whole discussion about this
uh
um
yeah I mean there's hundreds of emails
here
um
okay
but I'm not sure they're relevant I mean
I think
this is um
I I don't know I think maybe we're
better off starting scratch here
um
yeah we can do that 2019
this
old kinds of discussion about this
okay now I mean
we also have a lot of technology in our
curation pipeline that I don't know
whether this is I mean we do we know we
don't have anybody here representing
that like on for example no
um
could we maybe ping I'll and see if he's
around
yep I can do that okay
all right so
just so we're clear
I mean the basic thing here would be
some kind of human evaluate
that
you know defines an expression that
now presumably
I mean
what do we expect will be the typical
flow here for a human
it's like here's a question well it's
basically the question framework isn't
it
really depends on how you
feed it back into the system or uh the
the reinforcement learning uh loop
you are using the human intervention to
train an agent that then is used in a
reinforcement learning Loop so it's a
two-step procedure
then you have like something like Active
Learning well you have like a model
you're trying to estimate the weak point
of the model using the model itself and
then you are asking a human to to
provide more labels and then you are
feeding in those labels to train the
model again and continue the loop so in
that case the human is in the loop
continuously in the first case the human
is in the loop only only at the
beginning unless you want to train a new
agent
right but so let's look at our
Frameworks for doing this stuff so we
have the whole question object framework
right so in a sense and this is a new
thing that we didn't have when we were
talking about this before we have
exactly the mechanism because question
object we have usually imagined
that
its objective is
we are assessing the human so to speak
right
as opposed to I mean by the way we also
have the ask framework right that's what
first came to mind to me which is very
Cloud Centric but seems like
I think that's what we want here because
I think the edge of this has to be
you know maybe it's wrapped inside
Mechanical Turk maybe it's our own
system
it's something where you know humans are
being presented with things
so I mean what what's the basic idea the
basic idea is
somebody would log in I mean just like
our former kind of um uh volunteer data
curator program for Wolfram Alpha
which by the way we also might be able
to use because we had some technology
for that as well
um
yeah we had some technology there that I
think is interesting
um I think Alan would be the one who
would know about that as well
um okay
because that was a thing where you can
take a set of tasks I mean that's
that's more
in the offline way of doing this of
humans rate things
and so on
um
but okay but the basic point is what we
are trying to build up is
machine generated this
you know and human generated and then a
human gives a response here
so I mean okay the most naive level it's
kind of like forms right but the the
issue here is a sort of an outer loop
in which we say
these are the things we want want to
get resolved by humans
right I mean
are you looking for a general like
I need human input moment in a
computation yeah are we looking for
you know assume
that there's a pool of humans that you
have access to
okay which which
and somebody else will take care of you
know
pay the humans Etc et cetera et cetera
okay but if you see pool and and pay it
means section of a low low effort
thing but could it also be something
like uh this method of ND soul that is
that has been selected like is not
really working so do you want to keep it
or you want to change it
like something kind of expert knowledge
like you are looking for something like
this as well or just like no low level
labeling like is this a cat or a dog
just big big one well I'm thinking about
that I mean I'm thinking about what
I mean
I think this is more
you know this is the thing
that you know in a sense The Meta point
in chat GPT and so on is there's a lot
of information that humans have just put
out there on the web that you can forage
but then there's some very high value
information about kind of you know this
is how the AI is is going to do
something you know teach it type thing
and I think what we're looking for here
is
you know an AI has surfaced a bunch of
things where
it's kind of wondering you know humans
please rate this
am I making sense
rather than
I mean and you know you can imagine the
loop where the the AI is saying is this
better is this better type thing
but I think most of the time this is not
going to be an online it's going to be
an offline process
so I mean
you know from our point of view
you know what is the
um
it's really going to be something which
comes back you know it's not going to
come back instantly it's not like a
computer where you say
you know
here it is and it's back in milliseconds
right this could take two hours
so I mean I think it's more like
you give some computation
and I mean how does it work
if we have for example Cloud submit
okay
well let's look at how Cloud submit does
its thing
so it's going to be like session submits
or local submit
you're like offloading a competition to
a cloud machine instead of your awesome
machine
right I mean in this case you're
offloading to a human
to do it
right and and then you where do you get
the result back I mean if I say cloud
submit two plus two what's going to
happen here you get four
sorry you get a task object so you get
to to yeah you have to take assign it to
a variable and then get the get the
result out
well so okay so then we say
um
result received okay
okay so then we say evaluation result
what the heck
oh I think the task was clear out when
it was completed
I think the flow here is that you have
to define something to do with the
results
before actually that the whole task is
completed
this should be some example possible key
is specified by Handler function keys
yeah so you can say for example with
evaluation let's say you say x equal
evaluation result or something like that
so in this case for example when the
task is finished you get a dialog and
dialogue gets the evaluation result
right I mean if I say for example here
so the the simple one that you were
looking for is like Cloud evaluate no I
know
things like that
I don't know I don't think this would
can can work with you on a different uh
in a different kernel so this where
should this message dialogue work
it's sensitive I mean it's a different
link
maybe if you do print maybe it will
print in the message window or something
like that
I have no idea why Echo didn't work
because this is echoing to the my guess
but I I can be corrected here but my
guess is that he's echoing on the
notebook connected to the remote kernel
which is possibly no notebook
but is it it has no way to communicate
okay but this is coming back to this
kernel
uh
yeah that's a good point you know I had
this experience trying to get track GPT
to I mean I was connecting it
I was kind of amusing
I had a function which echoes
from a
custom plugin from chat gbt and it was
sending those Echo outputs in totally
random places like I found one in the
messages window I found one in the
notebook I was using it just sort of
sprayed them in different places
um I would expect Echo to put in the
message window in this case
well
I mean it did that's um uh
well if you if you do print it goes to
the message window so I assume Echo as
well all right so let's try this one
um
I know you open message
how do I do that window
the one before
and messages yeah right yeah
hopelessly
um
but it was uh
other screen okay if you don't drag it
here we can we'll see it so yeah it is
it is it is doing something there okay
fine
uh
uh okay
um hold on I can go fetch it just a
second here
well maybe I can
it's more difficult than you think
uh
oh yes there we go
wow
foreign
all right here's my messages window
fantastic
oh sorry okay so you also get the echo
yeah
yeah it looks like I did
for for evaluation result Arrow whatever
it is
okay in any case be that as it may
I mean asynchronous stuff is hard to
deal with here but
um you know so in the case by the way
did we manage to find Alan or not
um
no not yet I didn't get a response
Kristen's working on tracking him down
okay so I mean
it's
um it's just a little bit unclear how
this would work because as I say
your
you know best case it will generate a
task object where the task environment
is human
do you see what I'm saying
yeah
and then eventually it will be finished
and I mean so then what would happen is
this would at least conceptually it'll
pop up on somebody's machine and it'll
say do this stuff and then so I wonder
whether we can trivially do this right
now
um in other words the task
yeah this task
somebody would have to check out the
task right so in other words there will
be a queue of tasks okay so how does it
work generates
a queue of tasks
you know person picks the task that they
want to do
um you know when they finish
this goes back
through the through the Handler
through the event handler does that make
sense
that makes sense yeah I can assume we
might have like different uh like events
for example the like
this just started but we also have
maybe like when the task was submitted
when the the person accepted the task
yeah you'll have like you know like the
task time time spent into different
stages so you can like do something if
it really takes too long
task
uh
accepted by human basically yeah
task
underway
by human
task rejected by human I'm sure these
things exist in um uh
if you look at what exactly we should
look at some API that is doing this now
right but but from our point of view the
plumbing okay and then task completed
and then we have and then there's all
kinds of things about running checks and
so on but that's less relevant for the
AI stuff I have to say
you know it's just like the more you
have of these the merrier
um and this uh like a task it doesn't
block the kernel that's what we're
saying correct yeah so so you don't so
it's not you don't use this like in the
middle of a code that then it's
depending on the results if you want you
can do a task wait on it it's like a
single way right in JavaScript you
cannot you can always you can always
make an async code not a sync by by
waiting right but in the more General
case he is asynchronous
right I mean I think
this is
I mean the very beautiful remote batch
submit
um
this allows you so this is a case where
I mean this it feels very similar
because you know some of these things
you're submitting a batch job that might
take a day to run
yep
now an interesting question is whether
for Amazon in particular whether the
mechanical took credentialing system you
know authentication system is the same
as this one here
do you see what I'm saying
well I delete this with Amazon you have
one account but you can have access to
different I mean why can't could not
have uh any access to particular service
but I'll have to check this
right but I mean this here
looks very much like you know remote
batch submit
I mean an interesting idea would be
could we just use remote batch submit
for human tasks where the back end is
not a computer but a human
see what I'm saying
well I'll have to to check exactly what
what's the difference between uh
the sessions that meeting the remote
submit if this is no I mean just do do
some technicality of how um like no no
no no there's a huge
piece of infrastructure to do with how
this remote batch submit works it allows
you to access the job scheduling queues
and all that kind of stuff
you see what I'm saying
yeah so you you say that this is
strictly more sophisticated than uh
submit yes but it's more sophisticated
in a way I mean look at all this stuff
here
um
oh God we're gonna have
issues with child labor laws if we have
all these child thinking the same thing
it's different
um
uh
okay
uh okay so you do you see this as an
interface of some kind of
external provider like that we we wrap
it in in something which makes it
convenient to obviously I mean it
depends because I I can also Imagine
you know so Alan we're talking about
this human evaluate function compute
and um we're remembering previous you
know things like the volunteer data
program right
for which we built a certain amount of
infrastructure right
I mean
there's nothing that I think would be
useful in the present day I mean we we
look at some people spreadsheets and
asked them to send them back in and we
imported things
okay fine okay but
so
mostly okay and the other question is
our
curation pipeline stuff
which again may not be relevant to this
because it may be that what we're doing
here is a different level so that is
that
I mean I I I don't necessarily I mean
that that was the first thing I was
thinking of when I I'm trying to digest
what I'm seeing on your screen because I
don't know much more about this but
that's that was the first thing I was
wondering if that's going to be useful
for this right well I think the main
thing here is for reinforcement learning
yeah stuff
um
and the issue is
uh
yeah I mean I don't know to what extent
this thing is kind of a disembodied
thing as in you just say here's this
thing is it good or bad and to what
extent it's important to have kind of
real-time feedback saying you're doing a
chat thumbs up thumbs down at each stage
because those require somewhat different
infrastructure
um
from a machine learning perspective
is it because
you want a data set
and you you let it go for you know you
have like an amount of answers that you
want and when you have it you you you
you take the data set and you start
training
yeah
okay so it is it is very much offline in
using it right it's not like the robot
trying to feel its way around the room
with reinforcement learning somehow and
and or you know learning to balance a
pendulum or something or learning in a
game yeah exactly I mean this was a
point of the human envelope thing like
but
what was done it was they trained the
reward model using this and then they
put the role model into reinforcement
learning
so you are using this human feedback to
simulate human judgment a human a human
evidence
no no no what is using in real time is
that when you have the simulation you
have a model that simulates a human
evolution then you do the training in
real time the enforcement learning in
real time
but at that point what you're dealing
with two machines not not a machine and
a human
right but so for us in the reinforcement
learning stage so let's imagine that
we've got
um
I mean we've built a certain amount for
this and I always get confused by what's
actually useful or not in this case we
we built a little bit not too much
honestly and and this is one point like
if you want to use this for enforcement
learning I think we should first design
reinforcement learning from like ground
up because right
we had before was kind of crazy I mean
in my view because it was very weird
device framework yeah yes yep it's very
real time which I don't think is really
the point here right I mean in other
words
what what one wants is there is a you
know reward function type thing
which which basically just says
uh you know which is some kind of
function that could be that could be
obtained from the human feedback system
and then
what you're trying to do is training
against that function as opposed to
training I mean we we've had that in the
whole active classification thing and so
on active prediction thing right that's
that's surely what that is is something
which is trying to figure out how do you
poke at the function
see what I'm saying
yeah I mean the idea of this
is basically that you have a long list
of
unlabeled data
and you have an oracle function so here
this hash plus two is the function that
knows the answer
then you have a long list of data which
you you don't have labels for and the
point of active predictional application
is like uh
I should try to call like imagine that
the the labeling function is not like
something like this is more like exactly
a human or like an API call so you want
to use it as few times as possible
and
um you don't really care if you've
trained uh something based on a bunch of
uh human feedback stuff you've now
trained it and it's now cheap to call
that thing many times exactly at least
why you do that yeah
right but but so
so then in this case
what's the difference between so so what
you would typically want to do
is to take an existing model you know a
net model of some kind
and you want to basically tune it up
right with with um is that is that a
fair
you know
reinforcement train of the net model
with the training function
with the reward function
yes but this is this is generally
reinforcement learning yeah
right but the question is what we've
done in the past was a very messy thing
which involved you know worrying about
devices and real-time feedback and this
and that and the other I think what's
emerged now is that there is a form of
tuning a model so to speak
that
I mean you know actually let's ask a
couple of questions okay but but their
enforcement learning step is still in
real time like the this was my point
from from before like if we want to use
this thing
in reinforcement this is a separate step
that basically creates the environment
for enforcement learning right so if you
want to discuss it this is something
where this thing would run n iterations
and give us back a new net model yeah
and the fact that it it ran you know
everything is real time it's a computer
it's Computing you know it's not but but
this has nothing to do with the with the
human part except that the reward
function was created that way I
understand I understand so I don't have
a good design for enforcement learning
in general we don't know because
particular right but so to me
okay what would fine-tuning look like in
our framework because what we don't have
I mean we certainly have here's a model
now go train this model right we have
this that's it I mean you know if I were
to take you know net model of you know
eminist
of Lynette
data right you can take that model
happy happy model
and I could say Let me let me make just
for fun let me train it on
I don't know what I can do I can
pictures of cats and dogs or something
or pictures of let me do this let me let
me just make let me rasterize
um
let me make a goes to rasterize
a comma
dial
sorry of um
uh
rasterized style hash comma
30 and say something like this and let's
say that mapped over the alphabet
I've never tried this what's going to
happen you know what I'm going to reply
yeah
okay there we go Nat train
you need to revert this
I was the other way around right
thank you
okay
and then that train of the snap model
here boy this is really nice design wow
I never tried it this way well let's see
if it does anything
oh it should
oh no well because that you didn't uh
you didn't modify the network now you
you have to basically replace the the
output with the more classes
uh you have a you have you have 10 10
classes and a class decoder that is
going from zero to ten
all right so let's let's just do this
exactly so if you do that and then mod
mod 10 exactly
come on there we go okay
no this should should work
yep
cool asaurus
okay
is it surprising to you that's going in
jumps
well the the error rate is is uh is not
related he's not one to one to the loss
here because it's uh
uh
it's a piecewise Thing If It Moves to
one one letter or the other
okay great let's take this and as I test
let's feed it an S here
let's see what it does well I hopefully
it has learned the the training set
but yeah I know I know I know but let's
try okay let's just try something like
rasterize
Style
s comma 30 comma
want family
Arrow
you know
I don't know let's try this whatever
that is like time to see Roman oh you
have rastri sort of rasterize
okay let's try that
um
well you gave one example of everything
and he's also squished
because it's three sides to a square so
but yeah I mean in principle this is
it's gonna do something yeah right so
what we're talking about here is
the
I think what or if I can interpret your
mind what you're talking about is a
design meeting or enforcement learning
yes but I'm just trying to find out on
the basics here okay so
if I'm understanding correctly
like active classifier here
what we're doing the difference is
that whereas here
we are trying to make a prediction
function from nothing
in the reinforcement learning case we're
taking an existing model
and we're saying
I mean
in the case in this human feedback case
what we're really going to want to do is
basically just this right you've done a
bunch of human feedback
the only difference is the selection of
the questions that are look the loop is
something like this
but there's no no difference it's just
how we we wrote the function you can
start reinforcement in any loop with a
untrained model and you could have
active prediction with an already
trained predictor
that's just the initial condition
okay then then
let's be very practical okay we've got
some llm for example we're trying to do
uh
you know we've got
we're trying to do rohf for the thing
okay so it's going to surface certain
things where it wants a human to opine
right
model
surfaces things it wants to ask about
no this is again we need to keep this
separated
the way this was done was that it was
already unclear from the beginning you
had the the language model generating a
bunch of continuation and you ask the
human to rate those continuations
in this is step one then you take these
votes and you create the reward model I
understand
and so it's not the model like you you
know
okay step one you just said there are a
bunch of continuations write them right
what continuations what are you doing
the continuations of
well then you have a prompt Repository
well right okay attractions you you as a
as a engineer you you define that
maybe it's a problem proposal what you
did for the initial fight with
supervised learning
yeah I understand but okay so all right
fine so it's not surfacing
things it wants to ask about for itself
so to speak no this is what Active
Learning is doing yeah yes kind of
judging the performance like or
estimating what what is like the
boundary region
about right exactly that's what I'm
saying this is at the point where
Okay so
you know okay look the the thing about
training a reward model
okay we kind of understand that's you
know that is a supervised learning story
here right and for that
which is you know a fixed set of
questions and you want a human to opine
on the results
that's where humans submit
yeah in this case for example the
question I mean index that you're
thinking about the question is like you
have the this is this initial string
these like
10 ways to continue the string to sort
them by your preference
fine
and and so this is where the human
evaluate task
and then you get that the data set and
you do something I don't know like ELO
rating to to to take this training set
and make it into a scholar evaluation
yeah fine that's fine but then what's
the difference between what you do next
and
you're saying one thing I could do is
take that
training set I could you know one thing
is take the the human generated
you know uh input output training set
input output set
and train with that
but the but the other thing to do is and
train sorry sorry
okay yeah the original model and this is
what happens this is what this is like
step step one because you do an initial
fine tuning right so that that's that's
initial fine tuning
okay then the step two is
train a model from scratch
trainer reward model
from scratch
from the input output pairs
no no no no hair no this is the point
you train the role model from scratch
from the data that you collected with
the human submit
I know that's the input output okay
yes that's what I mean take the human
generated input to Output set okay you
do it twice okay this is okay let me
clarify the whole pipeline because
otherwise we look at it in different in
different pieces and it's never clear so
of a specific case of language models
what you do is you take a language model
you have a repository of prompt
and then you ask humans to continue like
those prompts like uh tell me these
follow this instruction answer more
nicely don't say this thing and uh and
then you saw you have the human
continuing doing the job of the of a
chatbot and then so this is the first
human interaction so this is the first
human submit that you know just continue
the prompt as a human and then you do
some supervised training that's normal
training of a language model like learn
to predict uh to predict the
continuation but now it's a human
continuation of a specific nature and
this this is the first bit then you have
a second human interaction which is now
you have a model which is better at
following instructions because it is
I've seen examples with the first name
introduction and you have it generating
uh like different possible continuations
like you asked for a question you have
like four answers and then the second
human interaction is rates you know sort
according to your preference these these
four answers
and on that sorting you train the reward
model
that is in turn put into the last step
which is an enforcement learning so we
have two cores of human evaluate let's
say in this in this uh right fine but we
the reinforcement learning part is a
part that
is like our active prediction
but slightly different packet
differently packaged
[Music]
um
yeah because active prediction is is
looking at specific
inputs where the the some external model
is estimating that you need to improve I
I know I know where you were given these
things here right
yeah exactly so you have this unlabeled
thing and you need to know when to label
them in in this case for for enforcement
learning
not expensive to code the environment
it's called like the Oracle function
here is politically environments because
you have the agent that interacts it's
like the nomenclature is from from
robots interacting with the outside
world
so so the the reward model here is is
the environment and the robot is is a
language model
but but I think we are looking at this
too closely to to this specific problem
like that but I understand I'm trying to
understand there's a final
you know reinforcement train or
something reinforcement learn whatever
it is which takes a model
it takes two models the the model to
train
and the reward model
and what is going to happen is it's
going to start selecting different
possible cases
and it's going to then
you know
see what this model this model goes
input to Output
and then the reward model runs on that
and
you know then then it has to adjust this
model and the output here should be
a you know improved model
right correct
I mean it depends it depends on on what
I mean there are several technique for
enforcement learning I think the one
used okay
right but I mean the and the issue is
you know one of the questions is which
samples do you take
you know in this case
this thing should be figuring out which
samples are worth taking
um no no no this is not typically what's
happening like the what's happening is
that the that you you you you still have
your prompt repository but in this case
differently from the typical training
you are not you're not getting an answer
token by token yeah like in the first
supervised learning or the in the
unsupervised thing because you you want
it to finish yeah so you you take your
repository you you let your model go and
and generate like a bunch of a bunch of
continuations from like you know 10
prompts 10 10 continuation and then and
this is all like hyper parameters this
is the reason why it's so finicky
reinforcement learning and then you you
you Unleash Your reward model and say
hmm I think you did well I think you did
not well and then you feed the score
into into the into this and then the
loss function of the model takes into
account the score
right but the whole point is you're
doing it on the whole output in the llm
case perhaps different from some other
cases like I don't know what you do in
the in the robot case that can also be
yeah because it depends like uh you know
if you if your robot needs to like uh
put a ball into a basket it doesn't
matter where it is in between yeah you
only you only can can give you know like
a well done when the ball is into the
basket or you could have a different a
different regime where you wanted to
take the the shortest possible
route so you you have like a
penalization
video game and it's it tries to see
whether it can do the whole game and win
exactly exactly of course I mean if it's
too long you have stability problems you
know because like uh I know if I just
tell you like well done when you win a
chess game it's very difficult to
understand what was correct and wrong in
the middle but the fundamental Point
here is this model to train has certain
I mean it's
you know it's not a single token at a
time it's the folded version of the
nested version of that that's going to
generate the whole output exactly is it
run it and then I let me read it okay I
like it I don't like it well the
question is here for this reinforcement
learn function we have to figure out you
know how what are the levers that it has
on the model
to train that it can change right and
that's where all these different
techniques for reinforcement learning
come in exactly like uh PPO or like you
have like the Cuba base I mean there's a
off policy on policy there's big
families what is the typical for our
case okay let's say we were using this
model
some very simple model here
what levels would be and let's imagine
that our
oh I don't know our full thing is
reading a whole word or something or
reading a whole number and
I don't know we have some loss function
that's based on I don't know exactly
what it would be but where
you know where it's this like like for
example let's imagine that our whole
function was
um
just something like map this over
you know a list
of letters and then you then you you you
hear the letters you join them into a
word and then you have to say is this
the right word or not something like
that yeah
yeah that's good that's a good example
yeah so let's do let's imagine that this
was letters and then we say uh string
join
of that and then we say Dictionary
lookup
you know dictionary word queue of that
okay this is this is a discrete uh
reward so it's it's been able to take
the gradient of this okay but yeah fine
fine fine so so it's like
I don't know how we do that you know how
close to uh you know how close is this
okay so now what do we do
you
um for example you you can uh
uh
typically what you want is is that you
want to
um
what are the levels that we given that
we've got this thing we've got this loss
function what are the levers we then how
do we know what levels we can pull here
enforcement learning model that you're
that you're using no I understand but in
the end you want to modify this net
model that the end goal is to modify
that net model
right
so I just I'm just asking how would we
get inside the net model to be able to
modify it given that we have you know
essentially what we've got here more
accurately is you know function of the
underlying model
right and what we're trying to do is to
train the underlying model based on
the reward model applied to the function
of the underlying model
is that right
oh well I mean the the reward model is
used in including in Computing the loss
so basically what you have is that you
you apply the underlying model to to
your uh do you thinking this is
generating in this case probabilities or
of letters for for each
and then and then let's say very broadly
speaking uh um you try to assign like a
value oh look look you've got some
function of the underlying model
that's applied to this function of the
underlying model is being replied to
data at every step
in in the case of an llm it's you know
keep running until you get to a stop
token
yes okay okay and then the whole point
is that what's different here is that
you are applying
this reward model to the whole thing
that was generated
yes not for the individual steps of the
underlying model
right
yes in this case yes
I'm going to claim it's kind of almost
the general case I mean like you're
playing a game there's a thing that you
know takes a step an individual you know
turn in the game
and then there's the whole picture which
is how you're going to win and lose
and then yeah but like for example stuff
like Alpha zero like the reward model is
more like that you are trying to
estimate the probability of winning at
every move
okay
but I think in the end this is but the
way you're doing that I mean in the end
you're going to win or you're going to
lose but that's the result of a whole
series of things whole series of steps
yeah I mean to be more precise than that
I will need to like refresh my knowledge
on this so I don't want to get too
detailed and possibly say I strongly
suspect this is right because I've been
quite confused about you know what the
minimal way to State all this is I
suspect this is it and then the thing
which is not obvious
is you know how do you dig inside that
function to go and make modifications to
this thing that's inside given that all
you're actually seeing you know in other
words so
yeah I remember this is the standard
problem you know how do you how do you
update
it's like you've got a big neuron that
with many layers how do you update
individual parts of that I suspect this
is correct but coming back to and this
will be a very useful thing for us to
clarify how this works right because
because I suspect this outside function
unlike the functions that we already
have built into into layers in a neural
net right where we know how to
differentiate them and all that kind of
thing uh you know the confusing thing is
that outer main Loop function outer loop
function is not as obviously you know we
don't have that in that same framework
that's what I'm saying so that's why it
looks different and more challenging to
do learning against it so to speak
um
I am going to need to go in a second
here but but um uh the um
uh
you know back to the human compute thing
for a second I think what's becoming
clear is that the fundamental operation
is
you submit a bunch of
uh of of
Quest expressions
that could be questions
and you you basically want people to
provide a mapping from Expressions to
results
and that mapping could be framed in
terms of the Expressions being questions
and the results being what they would do
in question answers that would then be
fed to an assessment function
or
it could be anything I mean it could be
like like what's the first word that
comes to mind given this particular
thing it's just some mapping from inputs
to outputs
defined by humans
and then the workflow we have to just
figure out is
just how do we you know how do we
present those as jobs in Mechanical Turk
or some other system
does that make sense
roughly speaking yes
is more like you know we it's very
similar to some like controls we have
you know it's like a like a picker uh
like a text field depending on what
you're asking yeah if you're asking
right but that's right to select
something the question framework exactly
deals with that issue
as to some extent does our form
framework
that's what I'm saying yeah
in other words the the issue here is
more the question of how do you present
it to whom who who picks the jobs you
know out of the queue you know Etc et
cetera et cetera how does that all work
that's which is where the whole
framework for you know and I think if we
can do that we now have you know we need
this additional kind of thinking for
this I really do think this line is is
kind of the the summary of what's what's
going on
um
the uh
but anyway so
you know I think what we should do for
the human submit thing if we think it's
worthwhile which I think it is
um is understand what these different
you know platforms are whether it's easy
to make a service connect whether for
example in the case of the Amazon one
the remote batch submit thing which
already works well on AWS uh could
almost directly be used for that
and I was not expecting that this
discussion would take up the whole of
our time here but it has
um so I think we have to wrap up here
um
and uh should I schedule a follow-up
meeting specifically for this like a
shoot off well probably I mean I don't
know what the priority of this is right
now I think it's worth I mean we've got
a lot of other things going on right um
we may need this
uh for some of the machine learning
projects we're doing in which case we
better have built it you know if we need
it
um so I think it will be worth yes it
will be worth a little bit of assessment
of how hard is this to build
um yeah okay and maybe Jesse who worked
on remote batch submit might know the
answer to that
from that side
and you must submit most of the work is
um
is like non-machine learning related
because it's like interfacing with
something I think so yeah I think that's
correct I don't think it's for your team
um I think it's for the service
connection team probably
okay and they may already have stuff
that was done because I know we did do
stuff years ago on this
so let's try to find that
uh
and yeah the part for the machine
learning team is more this reinforcement
Learn Type functionality
which I claim is not as scary and
undefined as it looked before
I mean what do we have I I need to go
but we have some stuff right for
this is such a horrifyingly not a point
thing I think
what is this where's the
okay these are the states but where is
the actual learning
no there's no learning here this is this
is just an environment
okay but how do we use this environment
what basically this is to generate the
is the Oracle function yeah I understand
how do we use that Oracle function what
function are we using we're using it
inside active actually you said nitrate
let me find the
if you search reinforcement learning I
should probably
uh
okay
open AI gym has
should hopefully some as an example okay
now this is just a link
not second
great there are the video games
that might have been an example I have
to check because this was done years ago
but might have been just an example in
marketing pages
when this was released about how to use
this but yeah let me let me check that
and then okay all right fine fine but
then I I'm I'm claiming that this is the
kind of thing we eventually need for
various functions here yeah I mean we
have we have several design proposals so
like if you have follow-up meeting I'll
bring up what Jerome did about this
stuff like last year and uh
yeah the the stuff we have to look at
that to look at in that case
um
okay but I think I think it's going to
be for some particular functions here we
can make this work
and um okay
sounds good all right see you guys soon
bye